dove sono e che luogo ignoto e questo è
una domanda che mi posso porre spesso
quando a 32 anni siedono nel consiglio
di indirizzo di uno dei teatri d'opera
più prestigiosi del mondo
forse se lo chiedono anche gli altri ma
questo gambetta e in 15 minuti cerco di
spiegarmi quello che secondo me vuol
dire tradizionalmente innovativo
parlando di me e del teatro e di cosa
può voler dire innovare in cultura io
fondamentalmente sono una persona
curiosa nipote di attori ho fatto danza
fin da bambina senza però mai aver la
pretesa di fare la ballerina e questo mi
ha dato un punto di vista molto
privilegiato ho fatto l'ultimo
spettacolo a palazzo delle papesse
dentro una mostra dedicata a lou reed
lou reed che oggi gli fischieranno le
orecchie perché l'abbiamo chiamato in
causa più volte che qualche anno dopo
avrei portato sul parco della musica di
roma all'auditorium
e proprio in occasione del mio tirocinio
di laurea in economia della cultura
perché sentivo il bisogno in qualche
modo di dare sostanza alla mia passione
cioè la cultura intesa come questa linfa
per nutrire la mia curiosità tre
settimane prima della laurea ho fondato
la mia società che si occupa di
produzione culturale e fare business
attraverso la produzione culturale
sembra un ossimoro soprattutto lui era
otto anni fa perché oggi in qualche modo
comunque si si parla molto di più di
impresa culturale si è sdoganato in
qualche modo il concetto di valore
sociale pur in ambito imprenditoriale si
parla dei liberi organizzativi cioè di
quelle realtà che pur avendo una natura
commerciale for profit in qualche modo
antepongono il benessere della comunità
su cui lavorano piuttosto che il proprio
ecco
otto anni fa eravamo tacciati dai
puristi per i quali con la cultura non
si deve lucrare e da altri per i quali
con la cultura non si mangia va neanche
posso garantirvi che si mangia su lucro
dobbiamo parlarne nel senso che per gli
imprenditori culturali il concetto di
look molto diverso oggi cioè per noi il
lucro in realtà e garantirci un reddito
dignitoso e la certezza è che nessuno di
noi sacrificherà un come dire la qualità
del proprio prodotto artistico pur di
mettersi in tasca un euro di più forse
perché sia attraverso come dire percorsi
manageriali ma forse anche solo come
attitudine sappiamo conosciamo bene il
valore di un euro perché non ci sono mai
stati dati in ottica assistenziale
sappiamo quanto abbiano bisogno di
essere messi a frutto e di quanto
contengano valori confliggenti spesso
quindi sia economici ma principalmente
sociali e culturali
sappiamo anche quanto è faticoso operare
cerca operare nel proprio micro settore
ma cercando anche di ritagliarsi un
ruolo ecosistemico perché sappiamo che
non possiamo esistere se non in un
ecosistema e quindi siamo gli stessi che
nutrono le proprie radici radicati
appunto nel territorio dove sono
tenendo lo sguardo alto
guardandoci attorno e valicando quelli
che sono confini sia spaziali che che
settoriali dall'altra parte c'è il
teatro comunale di bologna in generale
l'istituzione pubblica culturale
tradizionale per eccellenza
nel caso specifico parliamo di un teatro
classe 1763 che ha ospitato mozart
studente rossini verdi che ha presentato
per primo le opere di wagner che conta 2
160 dipendenti e un bilancio da 20
milioni di euro
tutto settore culturale bologna ne vale
33 milioni di euro
la mia società quando va bene 300.000
ora capite che le dimensioni contano
e c'è un gigante e c'è una bambina che
si trovano insieme e e si chiedono
perché hanno pensato che ci sia bisogno
di lei qui dentro
sicuramente per l'etica con cui sono
cresciuta non cerco di aumentare il mio
business attraverso questo incarico
sicuramente non porto capitali ingenti
quello che mi ci porta credo che sia la
possibilita la capacita di portare
visioni alternative modalità di lavoro
alternative e soprattutto energia che
sono il frutto di un percorso
diametralmente opposto a quello del
teatro
questo perchè semplicemente anche se è
tutt'altro che semplice
in italia la cultura sta cambiando pelle
e l'assistenzialismo pubblico che l'ha
caratterizzata negli ultimi decenni non
è più sostenibile e forse a guardarci ha
fatto anche qualche danno già diversi
anni fa mi chiesero di scrivere un
articolo e lo chiamai quale crisi nel
senso che in realtà non ero così
convinta che il problema della cultura
fosse la crisi economica e quindi di
conseguenza aver meno fondi ma che ci
fosse una crisi di funzionamento di
meccanismi divisioni e tra questi queste
problematiche sicuramente c'era quella
di credere che il settore pubblico e
settore privato fossero due cose a sé
stanti che solo che solo il settore
pubblico avesse diritto di titolarità
per portare avanti la produzione
culturale e che il settore privato in
qualche modo avesse sempre qualche
interesse occulto
ecco fortunatamente questa logica si sta
assottigliando
perché perché in realtà il pubblico non
sempre ha garantito di poi saper
portare tutto questo equilibrio è questa
trasparenza e forse perché i privati
hanno dimostrato invece anche di avere
serietà e competenza crescenti allora
piuttosto che continuare a farne una
guerra di fronti
io scelgo l'alleanza scelgo la
convergenza e credo che si debba sempre
più procedere in un'ottica di quella che
viene chiamata governance partecipativa
cioè di cessione di sovranità in qualche
modo equilibrata al volersi mettere in
gioco degli attori che in qualche modo
agiscono in questo ambito e sviluppare
modelli per la gestione di patrimoni in
questo caso culturali sia che siano
tangibili come le mura storiche del
teatro che sia che siano intangibili
come le arie delle opere che vi si
producono dentro dove il pubblico e il
privato ognuno per le proprie
specificità per le proprie competenze
per il proprio ruolo
se ne fa carico mutualmente
reciprocamente come si diceva prima per
riappropriarsi di quel patrimonio che è
molto diverso da appropriarsene
c'è una sottile differenza nel caso del
tc b o del teatro comunale negli ultimi
mesi da quando c'è questo nuovo
management e quando c'è questo nuovo
consiglio di amministrazione di concerto
con il comune e la regione con gli
interlocutori pubblici si è fatta una
vera e propria chiamata politica in
senso etimologico alla città
abbiamo chiamato gli imprenditori
privati e gli abbiamo chiesto di
contribuire cioè di dare soldi sì però
condividendo un progetto condividendo
una visione di teatro e forse
condividendo una visione di città perché
in realtà e quattro anni che in questa
città si cerca di ristabilire in qualche
modo la ricostruire gli assi del tessuto
culturale cittadino rafforzando e anche
dando sempre progressiva autonomia a
quelle che sono le sue istituzioni
culturali
questa chiamata a
fruttato un milione 2 negli ultimi mesi
speriamo che crescano ancora è
sicuramente la bonus ha aiutato cioè gli
sgravi fiscali introdotti dal ministro
franceschini peraltro appena
riconfermati ma io credo che abbia
contribuito anche il fatto di aver avuto
una visione di averla condivisa e di
aver riposto il teatro nelle direttrici
nelle come centralità somma del percorso
e di sviluppo della città
allora questo progetto di teatro
richiama il titolo del mio talk cioè la
cultura dentro e fuori cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che tu hai un foyer a delle
porte quelle porte vanno aperte vanno
aperte per far entrare risorse e punti
di vista e vanno aperte per far uscire
risorse e saperi i soldi privati ma
tanto quanto i gli ingenti fondi
pubblici statali regionali e comunali
che ancora concorrono al bilancio non
sono soldi dovuti qui è il cambio di
prospettiva
sono una responsabilità il nostro ruolo
è avere la responsabilità di questo
denaro e come nella più banale delle
partite doppie che ti insegnano economia
il nostro scopo è che i costi di questo
teatro diventino benefici diventino
risorse viventi non ricchezza per quello
che è fuori dal teatro cioè devono
tradursi in benefici economici culturali
e sociali per il territorio e per la
comunità che compongono la vita del
teatro che anima non teatro sia per i
professionisti che ci lavorano sia per
il pubblico che sia potenziale o reale
la nostra responsabilità e massimizzare
questi benefici in qualche modo si
ridurre i costi ma è anche lavorare
sulla qualità dei costi di questo teatro
cioè fare delle scelte che alloggino
quelle risorse in una direzione
piuttosto che un'altra
la direzione che abbiamo scelta è quella
piuttosto di fare una replica in meno su
uno
tra palcoscenico e farne una di più nel
prossimo teatro che nella prossima arena
che verrà aperta nel quartiere pilastro
la nostra scelta è quella di affidare la
regia di un'opera a un regista una
compagnia di teatro contemporaneo
piuttosto che a ai registi accreditati
dalla dal teatro d'opera
la nostra scelta è quella di aver fatto
una cola per giovani designer a cui
affidare tutta l'art direction della
prossima stagione
oppure quella di abbassare i costi
dell'abbonamento per i trentenni e gli
under 30 tale per cui ormai costa meno
venire a teatro che andare a vedere il
bologna allo stadio e allo stesso tempo
la scelta è quella di garantire ai
lavoratori del del teatro un equa
un'equa condizione dignitosa di lavoro
ma soprattutto coinvolgerli in questo
processo di ottimizzazione e di
efficientamento delle dei processi e
delle modalità in cui lavorano
questo concetto di apertura
se vogliamo di permeabilità mi porta ad
essere sempre più convinta di una
visione che o che sia manageriale o
politica io non lo so questo lo vedremo
per cui le istituzioni culturali
pubbliche devono essere sempre di più un
luogo di sperimentazione di governance
miste devono essere un hub devono essere
un nodo strategico che da un lato
permette di implementare gli indirizzi
politici che i soci fondatori
come dire giustamente danno chiaramente
nel rispetto dell'autonomia artistiche
gestionale di queste istituzioni perché
altrimenti non sono in grado
praticamente di operare dall'altro
devono essere in grado di coinvolgere
devono essere spinte a coinvolgere a
rafforzare accreditare proprio quelle
realtà private produttive del settore
che però hanno un percorso e una storia
diversa perché solo in questo modo si
riesce
a ristabilire quel ecosistema di cui vi
parlavo prima in cui ognuno opera nella
miglior condizione possibile per la
massimizzazione del benessere pubblico
del pubblico e in questo caso pubblico
significa audience significa le persone
che persone fisiche che fruiscono
dell'esperienza culturale significa
farsi carico della loro della loro
crescita intellettuale e anche della
loro felicità ci dimentichiamo troppo
spesso che della parola felicità che
alla fine è l'obiettivo della cultura ci
dimentichiamo che la cultura non serve a
niente non deve servire a niente se non
a vivere ed essere più consapevolmente e
più felicemente allora per concludere io
vorrei che fosse chiaro che non si può
parlare di innovazione culturale
pensando di distruggere pensando che
queste grosse istituzioni scompaiano
pensarlo e demagogico ed è assolutamente
banale non solo perché sono depositarie
della memoria storica non soltanto
artistica di questo paese ma anche
perché sono quelle che ancora in qualche
modo conoscono il modo per far evolvere
i linguaggi e di sicuro diverso e
pretendere come è giusto che sia che si
è ri attualizzino e innovare ex novo è
molto più facile che innovare qualcosa
che già esiste che ha già fatto i conti
con una sua storicità di sicuro innovare
ignorando i meccanismi del passato non è
innovazione
le tecnologie il digitale non salveranno
il mondo soprattutto quello teatrale
quello culturale perché in qualche modo
c'è un senso di protezione in questa sua
in questo suona cronies mo in questo suo
esser anacronistico così come noi non
salveremo il teatro solo perché siamo
giovani o perché apparteniamo a una
nuova generazione di professionismo
io credo che solo un patto tra noi
giovani professionisti e le più storiche
tradizionali istituzioni culturali possa
permetterci di salvarci e non solo in
ambito culturale teatrale possa
permettere in qualche modo di recuperare
quella vocazione di ricerca e di
contemporaneità che poi ha una
caratteristica fondante della cultura e
sperimentare e ricostruire dinamiche
nuove tali per cui il futuro non sia nel
migliore dei casi una mera
riproposizione del passato del presente
ma sia futuro vero cioè quello che non
conosciamo è quello di cui io continuo a
rimanere curiosa
grazie